[Music]
uh do you guys know who elvira is oh
yeah
dude i used to jack off so hard to her
during hollywood halloween is she adam's
family no dude she had her own show
didn't she yeah she she so during
halloween there used to be like these
movie specials and [ __ ] right and then
she would be the host where she would
every transition oh you know ghouls and
gals yeah cool yeah she looks familiar
and they've been i mean dude this
thing's been successful they've had
movies
there's [ __ ] pinball machines of her
there's like she's like in arcades like
like you can see her face everywhere
so she um is losing a [ __ ] ton of fans
right now why was she still alive she's
still alive oh [ __ ] she saw some big old
titties she looks pretty good too how
long does she go i mean is she like yeah
she like 80 years old pretty old where
do you think that she's losing followers
she probably said something racist said
something republican
[Laughter]
she's against the vaccine she said
something that is could be deemed as
racist she supports joe rogan she's
christian she's christian because you
know she's like
kinda
was it the fleetwood mad girl or the
girl from heart she went full christian
and stopped doing music and [ __ ] oh yeah
really yeah not that not that okay so
she she she came out as a lesbian that's
why people and all these guys are like
oh no shot now because she was like a
sex symbol are you [ __ ] kidding me i
thought that would skyrocket her stop so
boomer dudes are castling canceling her
they're yeah they're like yo i'm not
gonna follow you anymore cuz like i have
no chance with those titties those big
ass [ __ ] titties but these are actual
tweets that he's reading like other
titties now do we know how many
followers we're talking about like
percentage-wise or whatever she's lost
11 000. jesus christ just because you
said how many does she have what was she
starting yeah 13 000 or 13 million but
that's so dumb because she's just a
character like elvira's the character
yeah but the real person is lesbian and
they're mad about who knows her real
name nobody knows her name no one knows
her real name these guys are like uh
they've been sipping on her for decades
yeah sipping big time dude anymore
first thing i use the jackofter
these guys so she has 300 000 followers
so it's not really that big a hit yeah
but it is interesting that she's losing
people because this is market
retracement so that you know you can buy
the dip and push it back up is this on
instagram it's on twitter it's dumb
because that changes nothing for the
lives of the people that yeah jacking
off to her like i can't jack off tour
anymore
cal pen just recently came out too right
oh yeah he did oh yeah he's been having
the same partner for like 13 years wow
was that recent that he came out yeah i
think like the last six months i think
oh yeah he's a loyal man her name is
actually cassandra peterson oh that's
boring pretty boring yeah i like elvira
yeah
she's probably gonna get some new fans
though some support i feel like she
lives in a victorian home or a castle
she does not live in victoria
what is she just living oh my god she
lives in a modern ass house like bart
she just rides a broomstick
so you guys want to see what elara
actually looks like yeah recently you
have a recent picture make sure it looks
yeah when they look goth like that like
i'll do research dude
20 30 years ago you know under prime no
this is her
no that's what she looks like right now
no she's smoking high yeah she's looking
as great as my shoes it's not all pale
and [ __ ] let's see if we can get better
that's joe's type right there she looks
great
i like ginger she's a hot lesbian well i
don't understand why people well i mean
it's only eleven thousand out of what
three three hundred thousand that's a
lot though i feel like when you have
three hundred thousand followers losing
like five ten thousand or gaining five
ten thousand is the thing right just
yeah that's just kind of it's not like
she said elvira the character is now
lesbian yeah yeah you know like the way
that uh what's your name superman
oh jk rowling it's like dumbledore gay
or like the new superman's gay no or
bisexual oh yeah yeah yeah the comic
yeah in the comic game but he's like a
new character that's a different photo
how old is she though she's like bro
yeah she kind of has that uh she's 70
years old but she she doesn't have
anybody she looks like a soccer mom kind
of thing but she looks great for
something is there any way to find her
uh her net worth yeah [ __ ] yeah but it's
probably wrong she looks like a a 50
year old in las vegas it's just three
million no [ __ ] way
yeah that's just three million that's
because yours is true let's go
this [ __ ] is such [ __ ] man that's a
good flex right there i like that steve
just slipping that way let me see burke
i like social blade too like this
channel makes anywhere from eight
hundred dollars to twenty thousand
dollars a month okay you're worth four
million is that true i don't think it's
something i see exactly this [ __ ]
joke picture this picture is great
yeah they're really pretty yeah that's
true
that's true
you're trying to be sexy right now
what's joe's what's joe's okay jealous i
don't even know if i'm on there my name
is website are you even on it i don't
[ __ ] doesn't matter dude it's
credible it's cnn dude okay this is what
happens though because we we know i mean
do we know of ours worth three because
it's saying you're worth four it says
i'm worth three says joe's it says joe
has has 500 dollars
it's pretty good it's so true so true
what's next what's next if you type my
name in there's a guy it says 500 g's
for you 500 g's oh really yeah
that's very generous
if you type in nick dunn there's a guy
in huntington beach that was got in
trouble for saying mexicans need to go
back to mexico and his name is nick dunn
and he's white and he's not you it's not
me and it looks like you but just pale
so they got the wrong guy he's curly
hair you're saying somebody's out there
taking the rap for what you said that's
that was my quote that was my direct
question it says you're worth 19 million
bro i am oh oh
[ __ ] sweet so that's how [ __ ] off
that [ __ ] is that's see that's what's
wait you typed in ryan
he's worth 19 million dollars
oh that's that's actually the i owe 19
million for my sex offense
hey what are you not telling us why are
you even here dude what's going on he's
have you seen all the cool cars he has
yeah that's true i'll help you count
money dude
you sold all your cars and now you have
19 million dollars yeah i got a big ass
old fan to put all the cash in
do you think that has anything to do to
be being tied with lmfao and all the
stuff that you got involved i think it's
just it just goes by like whatever your
employment or whatever taxes you filed
whatever's public record your public
record says you got 19 million dollars
then i don't know maybe it's just my
debt they got wrong like wrongly read
1.5 million wow now we know that that's
absolute [ __ ] because i'm at least
200 dollars i can tell you right now he
does not have 1.5 million dollars thank
you
the true homie tell you that right now
say that right [ __ ] when the reality
sets in it's
i'm like uh is that
is that a nice thing to say right now
steve i thought it was a very nice thing
to say keeps you humble i can tell you
right now you do have three million oh
jesus so if you could just you know
share with us
i like these accusing people of being
rich
i like how people are like you guys you
guys aren't diverse enough and i'm like
if you look at all of our bank accounts
that's pretty diverse
19 million to 500 dollars five hundred
thousand no 500 g's
sir that's pretty good maybe i'm in
someone's will and i don't know and they
registered that'd be so sick i feel like
ryan's the luckiest dude in this room
though he's always just like coasting
and like getting lucky i definitely fall
ass backwards into lucky [ __ ] that's
only because gianni just left i know but
not monetarily just like
fun stuff what's some lucky stuff we
just fell into i mean just the lmfao
stuff was really lucky was that lucky
yeah but you also have the skills to
back up like work your ass off to like
[ __ ] that was insanely lucky because we
just like would run into him like we ran
into him at a concert and then that's
when he said hey man why don't you guys
choreograph this new music video and it
ended up being part of rock anthem
that's super lucky like we didn't we
were just by chance that's so crazy wow
you guys had massive skill to be able to
get somebody to be like hey you should
you know you know luck is when when
preparation meets opportunity exactly
it's that yeah and you're you you
prepared for that moment you know cause
if i was there and i met him at a
concert he's not gonna be like dude you
should choreograph [ __ ] my music
video i'll be like i'll do it
yeah that was pretty good too thank you
only time you guys got lucky was uh
what's it called the abdc or something
yeah we got really lucky oh yeah they
won
preparation that opportunity my friend
my friend
oh man how come you guys didn't prepare
that's why my [ __ ] net worth is not
you know 19 million dude you know
it's like it's 19 million it's 1.9
million 1.5 1.5 but clearly not though
debunked absolutely debunked
don't know how they gather all that
information like how do you create you
just send tax records from the
government i just assume whatever goes
to public record or they i don't know
what they do i wish my name was
associated with 19 million dollars
that's pretty crazy but that's bad it's
gonna look like i i'm what's it called
hiding money from the irs and [ __ ] but
you think the irs is going to use
celebrity network
iris is like okay time to do taxes
celebrity network [ __ ] it's this yeah
you should take that to ferrari
dealership but late it is how much money
i got this is my pay stub this is my
credit you don't need to look at that
trying to pull a loan net worth is your
credit
it's like those [ __ ] rims and tires
[ __ ] radio commercials no job don't
matter
no job just look up celebrity net worth
20 million dollars that's pretty awesome
just look at this [ __ ] dude it is
nowhere near like remember when my
coinbase glitch and i was making a joke
and i was like dude like so it was real
it wasn't no
ryan you're killing it it's good for you
man well there was that one glitch that
one time when he screenshotted where i
was like
what was it oh yeah luna went to like
seven billion dollars
and i was like and i was like i will see
all of you in [ __ ] hell
all caps but then that's how i know my
scale of wealth personally is so off
because i i put it on my ig story i'm
like hey look how funny it is my
coinbase glitch and it says i have like
700 000
and some some of my friends that are
like pretty well off were like why is
that weird
and i was like
why is that funny i'm like because it's
a lot of money and they were like oh
okay okay they're like that's there's
the funny i remember i texted you too i
was like i was like oh [ __ ] uh it pumped
up for you huh i didn't know because i
didn't read the glitch part or something
like some of my friends were like lol
that's hilarious and then other people
were like dude okay i was the lol that
was hilarious i said that
can i borrow something and joe's like
congrats man
crazy
or joe's like sorry to see that man
sorry it dipped on you
[Music]
you